welcome everyone to the second lecture
Thursday evening Thursday is the great
day of course to come to the Chess Club
so I encourage everybody who are in town
visiting st. Louis to see the Chess Club
and the big piece in France so Thursday
is the best day to travel and because
you can also see two lectures by
grandmasters it's the only day of the
week you can see that you can have that
opportunity to come see the club and
also he had two hours of training and
this game I'm going to show you it's
played in an Olympiad in my last
Olympiad as a player it's been a while I
missed out the last two it's getting
tougher and tougher to qualify so this
time I'm playing white against strong
Grandmaster Daniel Freedman six so if I
play 93 he were played in the yeah 93 he
will play the nimzo-indian defense so I
don't want night city so I play Knight
f3 d5
Knight c3 Bishop e7 Bishop g5 eight-six
questioning the bishop
Bishop h4 so your two main moves are
basic the Bishop f4 you can play or
Bishop g5 okay
these are your two very main moves okay
Bishop g5 or Bishop f4 g5 played h6
castles III
94
cakes
takes Roxy 1 and here I played a very
interesting more I want to give you an
idea here how to find my next move what
did I do here how to continue this
position there are many different ways
to play here as this what do you think
is the plan
92 Ashish Ashish 92 track is 92 a good
retreat guys I don't think so
a 3
Ashish don't don't just say moves I want
quality mph yeah we don't want just
moves we want quality moves with purpose
ok with an idea not just moves
what's the idea what do you think I
played here huh now the point here is
since the pawn is on h6 it's a little
bit of a target here okay and there is a
way to play aggressively to try to open
up the H file and you have two different
ways to start here you can play f5 or
you can play g4 here sorry you can play
h4 here or g4 if I play h4 sometimes
black can play a 5 so that's the reason
of I start with me starting this
starting with this very aggressive move
g4 okay now he goes 97
peach for
preparing to play g5 okay to open up to
open up the H file okay g5 take take and
open up and Queen h5 so I might want to
take Knight takes c3 rook takes c3 c5
and he is opening up the position it's
very logical my king is in the middle
and I've been pushing the spawn so he's
trying to open up the position makes
sense I take first he take okay now what
to do here how to continue g5 perfect if
he takes it very risky so he placed them
of h5
now I played Bishop gto just developing
okay just developing
b6
now what to do
because he wants to play Bishop a6
Bishop d7 and just complete his
development
what should I try to do here to have
some advantage
take some see if are correct if it takes
back at the pond I have Queen d5 so it
takes back with the night and now the
question is if I want to take that pawn
or not this is a very important moment
here to decide on do we want to take
that upon or what do we want to do
excellent
attacking on h5 attacking on d5 Nagas 94
well that might be strong when opponent
has a strong piece what do we do trade
them off right eliminate him now if he
takes back with the pawn I take on h5
that's a free pawn so he has to take
back with the Queen now attacking the
rook now what to do
f3 attacking the Queen now ego said he
wants to go Queen g3 are you gonna let
him do that
now he is trying to go rook c8 guys rook
c8 trade rooks and it's not so clear if
I have anything really really special
here so here is your chance to play
right okay and get a nice position here
here is your chance to play it right
okay
creating the Queens now if it goes to g6
I have a 5 even so it takes
he takes now let's try to stop here and
try to understand what's going on in
this position so to see who has
advantage what is going on here so I
think white should be a little bit
better now but on the other hand there
is only one weakness there's only one
weakness the pawn on d5 so it's very
hard to to win the position what do you
play
King f8
b3
f-five I'm not sure then it goes King g7
King disease
and what's the plan here what do you
think what kind of setup we have here to
try to win this position
huh look see Simon he goes King eh yeah
so kinky King date I didn't see anything
happening there
yes
yes well if the books come off I have
this quick efore before and then my King
gets in on d5 the thing is he's gonna
bring the king on these six we're not
really gonna be able to win the d5 pawn
anytime soon I'm trying to get this be
five square for my knight because I know
his king is gonna come in here and he
did and now change the character a
little bit okay see it takes I need that
okay you should gonna hold this that's
what he was thinking now I gotta keep my
rook on a1 I have to be able to do
anything okay one if needed okay now he
played a six this is a critical moment
here so I want you to calculate the rook
c8 move and then we can check the lines
okay do you think black and try to play
rook c8 it's very critical okay
can you play rook c8 and get away with
it
so the question is if he can play Roxy
it
let's just don't rush calculate can he
play rook c8 and get away with it
our she says no see the other strength
so let's see best rook c8 right
we take we go here here I think we're in
good shape and take take here we should
be winning again push and ft6
takes then the deep punk wins okay so he
has to take Kim Taek
here
and I think that eventually I have this
break you know which is six that will
give me the entry squares for my king he
goes to seven I can go to see six if he
goes here I can I have enough tempest to
get this in if you go see I have King g6
king f7 pick up test if he goes give me
seven I go King c6 c7 then I pick up yes
well because I want to get a king on d5
I want to get a king on d5 yeah
by the time you go around his King is
gonna appear on a good squirter you know
I just this is I think very close to a
draw now
no not King f5 so so here
yeah but I mean how are you gonna win
this you got the g6 in but
so that's why you don't have the time
for it so he didn't play that because
it's understandable so you played a six
but now you see the purpose of the move
rook c1 I go boom you give me that pawn
he has to play five and I go back
because he has this a four ideas so I
have to make sure I watch out for it so
I go here King g6 if he goes King this
six I have a four I say again give me
that I was rocked it
if I were Roxy several he's gonna meet
me with rook d7 Roxy six is gonna be met
by rock t6 so I don't have I don't have
a clear cut so to speak so I don't never
clear cut so that's why I go to d4 now I
want to go King d3 King to d4
so King d70 played attacking the pawn
and if he goes passively defending then
I just simply go boom boom and I win
this okay so he has to go here take
well if my King was on duty then I would
just win so now goes here so we get this
position now can you see so if I win the
d5 pawn and I'll lose the d5 pawn I'm
not gonna be able to win this most
likely okay so I gotta try to get some
ideas here what can I do here
my opponent was a little bit in time
trouble so I managed to get to get to
the winning position in a time control
yes I checked first to see where he will
go
he was king f5 and that gave me the
opportunity to play okay seven attacking
on at seven if he goes back to his six I
go to p7 I think I have good winning
chances
he played d4 it was the last move so he
says you know what let me get active but
this move it's probably it's just losing
now how how this move is losing what you
going to do
take one off seven
take on the first how it takes
g6 first because when I take on g7 I
want to have a strong passed pawn he cut
me off
what do you do push Ashish threatening
f6 Ashish now he goes here past pounce
meant to be pushed don't make a break
and now
if you put a d5 he catches you with kini
500k he catches you cut look at that cut
guys now the rook has to stay there and
I'm ready to push d5 d6 he checked came
here he resigned because he has to stay
on a G file if he moves away Ike win and
if he stays here I just simply push push
push push I get a queen and of course
very importantly if he goes here now
yep
now it takes I'd take you take an
acquaint results okay so once again I
want to go over the opening ideas very
important ideas okay for for you to
remember okay go ahead let's start
matter six
Queens gambit declined
and here you start with g4 again this
idea wouldn't come into you know you
don't think about it too much if it
wasn't like you know the pawn on h6 the
pawn on h6 is a target so that's what we
want to do that to put pressure okay no
egos here push there are other ways
black can play here as well so there is
a e5 move here right away to very very
interesting if I right away
take take ID to queen h5 interesting I
probably can play g6 some let's do some
positions like this okay clean g5 still
some pressure so there are alternatives
so he went here and here you don't want
to allow the captures on d4 on c4 so you
kind of want to keep it without so he
goes here
attacking to the palm
and this is a pleasant endgame not a
winning Canyon but it's a pleasant end
game to play okay not not easy to win
because of that one weakness so you have
to create the second weakness okay
that's what you do against the Queens
gambit declined okay all right now let's
take a look at the game this is a very
nice position block to play and win you
have to play like a strong grandmaster
LA snitch chica
any ideas please raise your hands if you
know it you have to claim a Grand Master
last Nishka we want to age five a g4
it's an idea but okay that's good but
you have to calculate Ashish that's a
good start but that's where everything
starts did you go deeply well I have in
that position I have Queen f3 move yeah
let's first of all Queen f3 is Queen f3
Queen f5 those two moves you want to
consider
okay so we start out with this that's
correct
he takes we start out with this now the
rock f6 is deadly so if it's a place
here you just check here check and
everything is hanging g2 is hanging so
you're gonna win this so the question is
what are you gonna do against this to
most Queen f5 or here first Queen f5 so
Queen f5
whenever Brooke de 80s and then your
thread think look II to check and look
III clean g3 but another ID actually
sorry another idea here is d3 no
threatening rock d4 Okafor very very
strong so take check now if we go Sears
check and take that guy
the Queen f3 now
we have a rope here that wants to come
in right okey three we have five two
eight now threaten check and mate on g2
and if he tries to defend that he
weakens his background when he weakens
his background what are we gonna do guys
check check check check check mate
got it yes if he goes to
g4 here
there is a five we can play a five
because if you take a look here okay
yeah
yeah this could be very strong as well
start with Duke t8 let's say rookie 3
let's see if we have that move
yeah
what about this I did is let's try this
and swing here that's another
possibility ruk ruk t6 Rock f6 okay so
let's see if there was anything else
takes the if you move the Queen just
takes this is rook f6 is threatened has
to play Queen f3 Queen f3 again rookie
three wins Queen a5 and the last line is
rook e1 I show you briefly but let's
make sure you have it go ahead check
check
now if it goes here you can just trade
and queen g1 pick up the rook and if he
goes here check
loketh - what's the game okay so unusual
idea you're sacrificing a piece and then
you're making a move that just controls
the squares okay but you have to try to
calculate this ideas okay look for
unorthodox ideas okay not always the
tactical tactics are gonna be the ones
that are just obvious sometimes you have
this unusual ideas not have to finish -
okay to get the win
okay any questions okay very good so and
we yeah we see the ideas here the night
is on a four and that's a weakness so
you take it down to show it like that
okay the night on the rim it's
definitely not helping to defend night
on the rim it's out of the game so
that's why this idea works because
essentially that night is not helping
all right great job guys thank you for
attending this class and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]